more professional success goes hand in
hand with better brain health thanks to
St media the sponsors of this segment I
spoke with a doctor that specializes in
this and is here to help you
I'm so excited to introduce you to our
viewers you do such great work you're a
mental health leader inspiring
professionals especially Muslim
professionals um to success so tell us a
little bit about what you do
I basically like to consider my I
Inspire Professionals in general and I
help them look inside oftentimes a lot
of these people have basically pretty
much accomplished everything that they
that most of us dream in life but
they've hit this this Rock Bottom point
of a crisis of meaning where they've
achieved everything and they're still
questioning like I'm still not happy
what's going on here and so what I I
find that my role is really getting them
to learn to have a relationship with
themselves because they've never learned
how to really do that wow a crisis of
meaning I love the way you put that in I
know social media has really helped you
touch more people than you've ever
thought you could um how has that helped
I mean it's helped because it's it's
validated that there's such a hunger for
this information and that a lot of the
mental health information out there
tends to be very textbook or very trite
and what I found is that when you can
kind of package this very deep
information in a very simple bite-sized
manner it people resonate with that and
they it actually makes it seem more
attainable on on one hand I'm very
fortunate because I work with a lot of
successful individuals who can't afford
therapy on the other hand though I also
work in a non-profit where I work where
I lead a team of mental health
professionals and they give access to
people who can't afford therapy and so
with downloadable courses it's really
another way to get people who can't
afford therapy access to knowledge and
information for self-transformation and
let's talk about your target audience or
your target group I should say
um the Muslim Community uh what are you
seeing there that are needing you know
extra attention well one of the things
is that you know looking at me I don't
work a job but like I consider myself a
very spiritual person and I find that a
lot of Muslims are kind of like confused
about their faith and about you know who
they are I find that you know from a
demographic perspective I appeal to
Young professionals or people who are up
and coming who are kind of not really
religious at the same time are not
completely liberal they're kind of they
call them the floaters and and every
single
um religion whether Christianity Judaism
or in Islam they find that these
spoilers are called 60 to 70 of the
demographic and they want someone
relatable that'll kind of understand
their struggles and that that someone's
going to kind of just preach religion at
them
I completely understand that you're it's
a judgment-free zone so that's really
important for professionals Muslim and
beyond that
um now I understand you're creating an
organization of therapists that are also
doing the same work yes so one of the
things that I keep learning I love
learning and I find you know I'm just I
can't I'm just one person so the best
way is to kind of use my knowledge and
no I can't and I'm fascinated by brain
science you know I've been told that I
have a gift in making the complex simple
so I find that when I can educate other
therapists in more in a simple manner
it's more inviting and they find it a
lot very helpful and useful working with
their clients so it's kind of like a you
know Pay It Forward where you just keep
sharing the knowledge thank you to St
media for sponsoring that segment for
more information on brain health with Dr
hamdan head to brainhealthgrowth.com
we'll be right back